after twin earthquake devastated parts
of turkey and Syria
we were all glued to clips of heroic
rescues
we saw teams from around the world
places like Spain China and even Ukraine
pouring into turkey to help survivors
but across the border in Syria while
there were some bright moments
victims were left to rely on local
rescue workers with little equipment and
they said far more lives could have been
saved if there had only been more help
Syrian victims also went days without
foreign aid so how did politics get in
the way of helping thousands of Syrian
victims what do Russia China and the
West have to do with the hold up and how
could the earthquake reshape power
dynamics in the region let's take a look
first check out this map this is where
the earthquake hit and these colors
represent the different factions that
control Northern Syria after more than a
decade of Civil War as you can see the
areas affected by the earthquake aren't
all controlled by the Syrian government
which is shown here in green this area
which was hit hard is the last major
region held by rebels who oppose the
government and president Bashar al-assad
Assad seen here on the front lines calls
them terrorists he's tried to crush them
and choke them off from a it for years
and he's had a lot of help from Russia
in 2014 the UN designated these four
border crossings to deliver Aid to the
Syrian people without Assad's approval
but over the years these three have been
closed that's because Moscow used its
veto power on the U.N security Council
to block them sometimes with the backing
of China Russia has said that the
crossings undermine Assad's Authority
and that Aid should be distributed
through his government in Damascus
instead and that brings us to the
earthquake when it struck the un's one
authorized Crossing Bob alhawa was
damaged just like everything else around
it roads leading to it looked like this
it took four days for U.N trucks
carrying Aid to cross into Northwestern
Syria which prompted Fierce criticism
many people started demanding that the
U.N Rush Aiden using any and every
available route essentially asking it to
ignore authorization from the Syrian
government and years of Security Council
press but that posed a huge dilemma for
the UN which was founded on the
principle of equal sovereignty for all
of its members in other words borders
are taken very seriously
so while frantic rescue operations were
playing out in Syria the UN sought a
private deal with Assad's government to
get access that private deal avoided the
need to ask for Russia's support to open
more borders in the security Council
ultimately Assad agreed to open two more
border crossings for three months but
that didn't happen until more than a
week after the earthquake
so what does this mean for the people in
Northwestern Syria
some say that the additional Crossings
came too late for search and rescue
efforts very few people were being
pulled out alive by the time they were
approved
[Music]
but they could make a huge difference
when it comes to helping Syrian victims
who are now displaced in the middle of
winter that's because the U.N can
provide Aid at scale both directly and
through other ngos on the ground in
Syria like the International Rescue
committee things like vaccines
Pharmaceuticals that would be really
difficult for the uh for the ngos to
procure ourselves and also food which is
another really big one are these three
authorized Crossings for the UN enough
it's welcome that they've got two
additional Crossings and those two we
know are feasible one thing to note is
the announcement says they're open for
three months and I think we know three
months is not going to be sufficient
now there are concerns that Assad could
use those Crossings as leverage when
they expire like by seeking relief from
sanctions which he criticized after the
earthquake
analysts also say the Syrian regime
which has been isolated for years may
use the earthquake to try to improve
relations with Arab Neighbors
since the earthquake those Arab
neighbors have sent Planes full of food
and Aid to government-controlled Regions
and some have come to meet Assad in
person something the U.S has been
watching closely we don't support
normalization of relations with the
Assad regime reestablishing those ties
could help Assad attract more investment
in Syria which was badly needed even
before the earthquake but experts don't
expect the front lines of the Syrian
Civil War to change and for the millions
of people living in the rebel-held
territory their future could become even
more dependent on foreign aid
thank you